Hey guys! So today. I'm making my dog, dog treats.
He is
on a very specific diet when he was little (he had tons of allergies)
Basically spent like the first year of his life in and out of the vet's, dermatologist
We tried every possible food combination, and even now he has a very sensitive stomach, so my mom always makes these dog treats
but I ran out, so now I
have to make the dog treats myself, so prepare yourself, guys, for a dog cooking episode.
Do we really consider any of my YouTube videos episodes? We're making dog treats today. Let me go get the ingredients.
I'd also make sure you get unsalted and unsweetened peanut butter cause you don't want your dog to have any of that.
Okay, we're got all of our ingredients set up. Now we need to put it all in and we're going to make it. We're going to make our stuff.
Ahhh!
God, I'm making a mess. Well, I think this looks pretty good.
I had to add extra water, because I put too much peanut butter in and some things were off.
So, you know you gotta do what you gotta do?
Go back in there. It says you can roll them into little balls, which I'm also going to do
But I'm also going to roll some out into some nice flat little
circles.
Perfect. Perfect little Matty treat.
I don't even know if this is gonna work , to be honest with you. Probably should have put it in the fridge first.
Oh, this is working great!
The oven is preheating to 350 and we've got our first tree done. Look at this!
Rolling these out is taking a lot longer than I thought, so I'm probably just going to do the next batch of little round balls
Because this is quite a process. I don't even spend this much time making food for myself.
Alexa, set a timer for 22 minutes. "Setting timer, 22 minutes, starting now."
The cookies are in the oven. I decided to do two batches of the cookie cutter ones, but I still have some left over
So I guess I'll just kind of make those on another tray, and hope for the best and wait for these ones to finish up,
and then
Matty can try his treats!
I also like to put these in the freezer because I don't use them that often so I do like to keep them either
refrigerated or in the freezer. Now, you actually like some more frozen so, note.
Do you have any idea what I'm doing right now?
Lovin' life. That's my boy.
Oh God, it's so hot! Here they are.
It looks good.
I'm gonna let those cool, and then we'll see if Matty likes them, my angel!
Before Matty tries them, I have to try them.
I mean, it just tastes like cooked peanut butter. It's not bad but it's surely not good. We'll see if Matty likes it.
Have a treat, come here! Fist bump. Yes, that's my angel! Sit! Lay down! And tell me if this is good?
Aww.
Good boy!
Is it a good treat?
High five!
Yes, that's my baby boy!
Up, up, up, up, up!
Now it's time for his ultimate trick. My dog... can DJ!
So, that's my dog. That's why we call him DJ Mini Matt. Get a kiss! Woah!
He's had both, oh goodness! I'll put the recipe in the description if you guys want to make this. Also,
I'm super excited because he loves them and I know what is in them
One of the hard things about getting dog treats for dogs, most stores sell dog treats with stuff in them
that are not actually good for your dog. Of course, you should always treat moderation.
Let me know if you guys have any recipes or things you can make for your dogs. I would love to see them
I'll see you guys in my next video. Bye!